bien pues esta es tu oportunidad de
utilizar una balanza para saber cuánto
pesa un objeto bueno en este caso vamos
a pesar a este amiguito verde que está
aquí que se llama viejo lobo de mar y de
hecho es lo que nos preguntan cuánto
pesa viejo lobo de mar y lo que podemos
observar es que la balanza está en
equilibrio y luego nos dicen que viejo
lobo de mar su peso más seis bloques es
igual a ocho bloques de lo que se trata
es quitar o poner bloques bueno ya
veremos qué hacemos de manera que
tengamos sólo de un lado al viejo lobo
de mar del otro lado los bloques que
correspondan la balanza se encuentra en
equilibrio y así sabremos cuánto pesa
viejo lobo de mar pero hagamos primero
una exploración y por ejemplo qué pasa
si yo quito un bloque del lado derecho
bueno si yo quito un bloque del lado
derecho este sube y claro perdimos el
equilibrio
de hecho nuestra expresión ahora nos
dice que no tenemos una igualdad pero
bien estamos explorando entonces lo que
yo voy a hacer es regresar el bloque que
había quitado y de acuerdo todo está en
equilibrio entonces ahora del lado
izquierdo voy a quitar un bloque
pero definitivamente tengo que hacer
algo si yo quito algo del lado izquierdo
tengo que hacerlo del lado derecho
también entonces ahora vamos con el lado
derecho
perfecto ahora vamos otra vez con el
lado izquierdo otra vez con el derecho
muy bien vamos muy bien quito otro del
lado izquierdo y otro del lado derecho
lo repito otra vez una vez más
ya nos estamos acercando y una vez más y
por fin lo logramos la balanza está en
equilibrio y viejo lobo de mar pesa dos
bloques y bueno en este ejercicio que
puedes hacer en nuestro sitio te estamos
proporcionando toda una serie de
información de todo lo que ocurrió de
hecho empezamos con esta expresión que
se encuentra aquí y lo que hicimos fue
restar seis de ambos lados como puedo
observar aquí y finalmente para llegar
la solución que viejo lobo de mar o
también podemos llamarle x tiene un
valor de 2 bueno es el momento de
comprobarlo
y todo salió muy bien nos vemos en el
próximo vídeo